humanity going through some very very
important kind of transition
into some kind of new relationship to
universe i'd say that the kind of
acceleration that would occur
after the child has been formed in the
womb
taking the nine months
and and then starting against the issue
from it from the womb
out into entire new world
you guys
but mr fuller is right
earth has been through a tremendous
evolution
and
we're shifting more and more into
abundance
for all
greater unity and greater love
greater actualization of everyone's
potential
and
it is a lot like the gestation process
and being
birthed
into this new paradigm
and there's no better way right now to
support this new paradigm
than by joining home dao
you're registering to vote for the
planet
by decentralizing public goods
infrastructures
meaning water food
energy
housing
both residential and communal
education
health care
all of these
main
foundational public goods to be
decentralized
so that our basic needs are met across
the world
in a sustainable and regenerative way in
harmony
with earth
for all of us to be able to actualize
our highest potential our creative gifts
to
ourselves
to our families
friends and the world
so
get involved in homedow register to vote
for the planet by decentralizing public
goods
you can check out all the information
below
infinite love